نريد أن نذهب الآن إلى جوناثان كريز
المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي أه جوناثان هل
أنت هناك هل تسمعنا
نعم أنا وأستطيع سماعك بصوت عالٍ
وواضح لذلك نريد أن نحصل على أه ردك
على أخبار هذا المستشفى في غزة أه
وبحسب ما ورد قُتل ما بين 200 إلى 300 شخص
هناك في هجوم صاروخي واضح
تقول حماس إن هذا كان
جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، ما هو
ردك؟ الرد الأول هو أن أي شيء
تقوله حماس يجب أن يؤخذ
بحذر شديد وتشكك،
وأحث جميع الصحفيين على  كونوا حذرين للغاية
عندما ينقلون ما يقوله كاماس وعندما
يعتمدون تقاريرهم على تلك الأحداث،
ما يمكنني قوله هو أننا قمنا بتحليل
مصادر مختلفة للاستخبارات والأنظمة
والمعلومات التي لدينا
والتي تم تأكيدها من قبل أعلى
المستويات في جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي هي  فيما يلي، نحن
على علم بوابل من الصواريخ التي
أطلقها الإرهابيون من غزة
باتجاه إسرائيل والتي مرت على
مقربة من ذلك المستشفى في غزة في
الوقت الذي أصيبت فيه المعلومات
الاستخبارية التي لدينا من
مصادر متعددة، هل تشير إلى ذلك؟
حركة الجهاد الإسلامي هي منظمة إرهابية أخرى
في غزة مسؤولة عن
إطلاق صاروخ فاشل أصاب
المستشفى في غزة،
لذا فأنت تقول إنه كان هناك
شيئان يحدثان هنا، حماس، سلسلة
من صواريخ حماس التي كانت تمر،
ولكن بعد ذلك أيضًا هذا هو
فشل
إطلاق صاروخ من الجهاد الإسلامي، نعم خلاصة القول هي أنه
وفقًا لتحليلنا الاستخباري
وأنظمة التحكم الجوي المختلفة التي لدينا وما إلى ذلك،
تشير إلى أن هذا كان
إطلاقًا فاشلاً وليس بشكل عام ولكن على
وجه التحديد من قبل الجهاد الإسلامي
وجوناثان، ومن الواضح أن هناك ما سيحدث  يجب أن
يكون هناك تدقيق هائل من جميع أنحاء
العالم حول السبب الدقيق الذي أدى إلى هذه
الضربة الصاروخية على
المستشفى وأريد فقط أن أشارك
مشاهدينا وهم يشاهدون مقطع فيديو
صاروخيًا جديدًا أخطأ في إطلاق الصواريخ وليس
ضربة صاروخية، لم نضرب ذلك
المستشفى أه لذا أ  عفوًا عن الضربة الصاروخية،
لكنني أردت فقط أن أشارك
مشاهدينا مقطع الفيديو الجديد الذي نتلقاه
عن الضربة ومع ذلك
قُتل مئات الأشخاص، سيكون
هناك تدقيق هائل حول من كان وراء
هذه الضربة، هل أنت على استعداد لمشاركة هذا الهجوم الصاروخي؟
المخابرات البيانات الأولية الفعلية مع
العالم تشير أه ما
تقوله أن هذا كان الجهاد الإسلامي وليس
الجيش الإسرائيلي نحن في طور
رفع السرية لا أستطيع أن أعدك بعد بأننا
سنفعل ذلك ولكن ربما بسبب
الأهمية وبسبب  ما هو على
المحك هنا قد يحدث ولكن
الحقيقة المهمة التي أستطيع أن أقولها الآن
لأول مرة على شبكة سي إن إن هي أننا لم
نضرب ذلك وأن المعلومات الاستخبارية
التي لدينا تشير إلى أنه كان
إطلاق صاروخ فاشل من قبل
الجهاد الإسلامي و  أريد أن أضيف بشكل قاطع
أننا لا نقصف عمدًا أي
مرافق حساسة
أو أي مرافق حساسة وبالتأكيد ليس المستشفيات،
فنحن ندرك تمامًا وجود
المدنيين وندرك تمامًا
التلاعب الساخر الذي
تسعى حماس إلى القيام به باستخدام المدنيين بشكل دقيق.
لهذه الأغراض، وقد رأينا ذلك طوال
سنوات الصراع العديدة التي
شهدناها مع حماس، وأكثر من ذلك، خلال هذه
الحرب ليس لديهم حدود، فهم يقصفون
المدنيين التابعين لهم، ويهاجمونهم،
ويستخدمون العنف، وفي هذه الحالة
ما حدث  هو أنهم يحاولون
الاستفادة من هذا الحادث المؤسف المتمثل في فشل إطلاق صاروخ
من صواريخ الجهاد الإسلامي من أجل
زيادة الضغط على إسرائيل. هل
تقول أنه بيقين
100٪ يمكنك القول أن هذه لم تكن
ضربة صاروخية لجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بشكل مؤكد مثل أي شخص في الحرب؟
يكون هناك مليون قطعة من المعلومات
المتطايرة ولكن بعد مراجعة جادة للغاية
أستطيع أن أقول إن هذه هي
المعلومات التي لدينا الآن ونحن
واثقون والمعلومات التي لدينا
تقول أن هذا كان إطلاقًا فاشلًا
من قبل الجهاد الإسلامي
وكان جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي  كانت هناك
هجمات صاروخية للجيش الإسرائيلي في هذه المنطقة في
الوقت الذي كانت هناك عمليات عسكرية مستمرة
للجيش الإسرائيلي في
مواقع مختلفة في جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة، وكان هناك
أيضًا إطلاق صاروخي مستمر وتم
إطلاق الإنذارات في إسرائيل في
وقت الغارة المبلغ عنها أو
المبلغ عنها  انفجار في المستشفى، كنت
بنفسي في الطريق وكانت هناك
صواريخ قادمة باتجاه تل أبيب
وتتجه، أريد فقط أن أكون
واضحًا جدًا بشأن هذا الأمر للحصول على
مستوى اليقين الخاص بك جوناثان لأنك
تقول ذلك هناك  هل كانت
الضربات الصاروخية الإسرائيلية في جميع أنحاء أه
الجزء الشمالي من غزة ونوعًا ما في
هذه المنطقة في ذلك الوقت على وجه الخصوص بالقرب من
هذه، لم أقل أنك قلت في
المنطقة، نعم صحيح، لذلك اسمحوا لي أن
أكون واضحًا أريد أن  دعني أطرح
سؤالي، دعني أطرح سؤالي
عنك، جوناثان، هل كانت هناك ضربات صاروخية
بالقرب
من هذا المستشفى داخلك، تعرف كتلًا
من هذا المستشفى في حي
هذا
المستشفى، وليس بقدر ما أعلم أن
تحقيقاتنا قد تركزت  عند
التأكد أولاً من عدم وجود أي
استهداف متعمد تم
التأكد منه بشكل كامل ومراجعة أخرى
لأنظمة الاستخبارات التي لدينا من
رادارات وغيرها تشير إلى أن
هذا كان إطلاقاً فاشلاً من قبل
الجهاد الإسلامي، هذه هي المعلومات المتوفرة
لدي.  لقد تمت الموافقة عليها من قبل
أعلى المستويات في جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي وهذه هي
المعلومات التي نقف بجانب
جوناثان ومن الواضح أنه سيكون هناك
كما لاحظت الشكوك من جميع
أنحاء العالم بسبب ادعاءات حماس
والجماعات الأخرى حول أه الطريقة
أن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي أه قام
بعمله تاريخياً في غزة ماذا
تقول لأولئك الذين لا يصدقون ما
تقوله، استمع إذا كان يصدق إيدا
أو يصدق حماس، أعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون
واضحًا لأي شخص معني أنه
يجب أن يصدق  جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي نحن لا ندعي
الكمال، نحن نرتكب الأخطاء بالتأكيد
ولكننا نطمح دائمًا إلى قول الحقيقة
وأن نكون شفافين وعندما تكون هناك
أخطاء فإننا نملك
أخطائنا ونوضح ذلك
هذه المرة ما أقوله هو  أن هذا
بحسب المعلومات المتوفرة لدينا كان عملية
إطلاق صاروخية فاشلة وليس من قبل حماس وأنا
أقول على وجه التحديد اسم
المنظمة لأن ذلك يشير إلى
مستوى المعلومات التي دخلت فيها،
وكانت حركة الجهاد الإسلامي هي التي أطلقت
صاروخا بعيد المدى  نحو
هدف بعيد المدى، فشل وانفجر، وهذا ما
حدث في المستشفى، لذلك
أنت تقول إنهم أخطأوا
هدفهم
بشكل أساسي، نعم، استمع، لقد حدث هذا
في كل صراع وأي شخص
يتابع قتالنا مع
حماس يعرف ذلك  أنه في كل مرة يتم فيها
إطلاق صواريخ باتجاه إسرائيل،
لنفترض أنهم يطلقون بعض الصواريخ، هناك
مئات من الأخطاء في هذا الصراع
وحده، كان هناك أكثر من 400
خطأ في هذا الصراع وحده، وفي
الصراع الأخير في 21 مايو كان لدينا
نفس العدد  تقريبًا نفس كمية
الصواريخ التي تم إطلاقها والصواريخ التي سقطت
داخل قطاع غزة. أتذكر
بوضوح حدثًا تم نقله على الهواء مباشرة
على قناة فوكس بواسطة تري ينجست حيث كان
يقف داخل غزة، وكانت التقارير التي
صدرت عن غارة إسرائيلية
وهو أمر غريب.  ترددت أنباء في جميع أنحاء العالم،
لكنه ذكر بعد ذلك أنه رأى
بأم عينيه ضربة أدت إلى سقوط صاروخ
أخطأ الهدف وسقط في شمال
غزة. أعتقد أنه كان جباليا وتسبب في وقوع
إصابات ومقتل
عائلة فلسطينية، لذا فإن هذا ليس أمرًا غير مسبوق.  لقد
حدث ذلك عدة مرات في الماضي،
وهو موثق، وبالنسبة لأولئك الذين يرغبون في
الاستماع وعدم إلقاء اللوم على
إسرائيل تلقائيًا، هناك دليل واضح على
حقيقة أن هذا قد حدث عدة
مرات من قبل، ليس في مستشفى
ولا في الكثير من الحالات، ولكن الحقيقة
والأمر هو أن الصواريخ تخطئ وتسقط
في غزة، وهي تفعل ذلك منذ
سنوات